[Music]
on today's show we talk about
draining friendships adult kids with
anxiety and depression
we talked to a wonderful new military
wife who's already exhausted by all of
the moves
stay tuned hey what's up everybody this
is the dr john dalone show
i'm john and i hope you're doing well
i can't get this song how do i live
without you
out of my head and it won't leave
james why why is it there in the first
place i haven't heard that song probably
in 15 years
and all the way on the drive into work
today i didn't have any radio on
i was just listening to that song over
and over and
i was in walmart the other day because
i'm a classy shopper
and i found the master puppets record cd
for five dollars
inside baseball i have a cd player in my
car nothing else not even the little
wire that goes to my phone
and so i still look for cds at a bargain
price
and there's one store on earth that
still sells them
phenomenal record has nothing to do with
who sings how can i live without you
bien rhymes also trisha yearwood
but master of puppets i highly approve
of that purchase i
just think y'all's cool points just
totally plummeted you both
rattled off leanne rhymes clearly
because i i do live in nashville
and you have her name tattooed on your
arm hashtag just saying here
and i was a country dj for seven years
dude i worked in the industry for 20. so
john thinks it's the first show we've
ever worked on
i'm going to go with it so welcome
everybody the doctor johnny show we're
so glad you're here
i work with a bunch of jerks who hurt my
feelings and
i'm just trying to sing along here oh
man hey
if you want to be on the show give us a
call at 1-844-693-3291
if you want to talk to me a kind human
being who loves each other didn't you
start this off by calling us
nerds and jury how can i live without
you
844-693-3291 or go to
johndaloni.com or you can
write an email to ask john
ramseysolutions.com
and we would love to have you on the
show to either a be
harassed and harangued by the gang or
thoughtfully um
i don't know how to say that do you talk
to me too that's cool man
um hey it is good to see everybody and
it's been a long time since we shot some
shows so it's good to see y'all
all right let's go to the phones let's
go to aaron i guess it's not been a long
time we shot one yesterday so i just i
made that weird so let's go to aaron in
allentown and aaron you can join us on
the train wreck of a show that we
are rocking and rolling with today how
are you i'm good doctor john how are you
i am good so good so so good so what's
up
how are you um i'm doing well first off
i just want to say
thank you your words have made an impact
in my life more than you know for the
better but first off just want to say
thank you you're so lovely thank you so
so much for saying that
appreciate that so what's up how can i
help
so i was wondering and have been
wondering for a while
should i continue friendships if they
are draining to me
out of the gate i would just say no tell
me more about what you're thinking
so when i hang out with certain friends
like
um i'll enjoy my time but afterwards
i'll just feel like
a lot of energy just like got pulled
from me and i don't know whether it's
the person
me personally just how i process things
or
if it is the friendship itself that
needs to end
are these long-term friends or just
buddies this happened with everybody
tell me about
how you feel when you feel how you feel
it sometimes happens with everybody um
and it'll usually be like right after
i'll stop hanging out with them that
i'll like be like okay wow
that took a lot of energy for me to just
be there and hear all their information
and process
everything they're going through because
life is heavy and for some reason
a lot of people tell me they're heavy
stuff so i just feel like i have
i have that to deal with in addition to
my heavy stuff right
i sometimes don't get to share so do you
have relationships in your life
that you leave energetically that you
leave
fulfilled um
there are few and far between but yes
there are some tell me about one
it's with my mom with your mom
who's somebody who's somebody that's not
your parent
to be really honest i don't have one
that's not a family member
um so when you go hang out with your
friends
um your community members folks that
aren't your family members
what do you hope to get out of
that friendship that relationship
oftentimes i i just kind of want to
leave refreshed and be encouraged
um and sometimes i don't get that and
maybe that's an expectation
that is unrealistic to put on someone
else
um so what do you get from your mom
that you don't get from your friends
i'm listened to and i'm hurt out hmm
so here's my thinking
and i'm just going to talk out loud for
a second is that cool
yep okay so with
our parents they often not
not everybody experiences this but often
they'll doubt on us
they will make the whole world about us
right and that feels so good
um but it can become transactional
meaning i go to them so that i
get something and
i think that can ultimately drain
friendships
when you try to go to other people for a
thing
instead of approaching friendships in a
more of a service-minded um service
mindset
what can i bring to these this group of
people
and hopefully those people that only
works if they're bringing that same
thought to you right so we all have
friends or community members or people
that we know that are vampires
we show up with the service mind
attitude like we
bring drinks every time we show up or we
bring food or snacks we make sure if
we're watching the fights we always
bring the money or whatever the thing is
and we bring funny stories and we bring
our challenges and hurts
and they bring theirs and everybody kind
of puts it on the table and that's what
friendship is right it's it's
what can i can i tell you the good stuff
can i tell you the bad stuff and we
still love me
right and
man if you show up to somebody and they
don't reciprocate they just drain drain
drain
yeah that's hard that is so hard
i have experienced what you're talking
about one because i'm kind of an
introvert
i fall right on the line of the
introversion extroversion if you believe
any of that voodoo witchcraft which i
usually don't but
i'm more of an introvert i like being by
myself
i get um lifted up by that but i found
that when i hung out with people and
it was all about me i left more drained
why did i say that what did i say i
can't believe i told that story
it was really i was looking at those
engagements as a performance
did my audience respond in the right way
they didn't like that i said that i may
have exaggerated that story too much and
when i quit doing that and i just
started showing up being fully myself
and if somebody kept droning or whining
and i would say
hey dude just get over yourself quit
quit whining
and they would stop and then i would
tell my jokes and we would have fun and
we would engage and i would say how i
could support you
when i started just being fully myself i
quit leaving interactions that way
does that make sense that makes
a lot of sense yeah and it hit home when
you show up does it ever feel like you
you're performing versus you just the
people around you your friends
just accept you for aaron
i i definitely do leave situations
questioning why i did certain things and
overthinking things
ah okay i think i'm realized why do you
do that
why do you think you leave giving
yourself a rundown of your performance
i just feel like i always can do better
um
i guess i'm worried that i'm not going
to be upset like accepted for
what i lay on the table too ah
tell me more about that
i don't know it's just life is messy so
why would someone want all of my mess so
it's hard to
kind of think when sometimes like i
don't want even all of my messages
so listen aaron 1 000
you're worth having friends and you're
worth being friends with
and the cool thing about having friends
in community is
when you've got more mess than you can
handle they're there to
pick up the other side of that couch and
when they've got more mess than they can
handle you're there to show up with
pizza and tacos
right that's what that's what community
is and it goes
seasonally right and sometimes your
friends are really in the thick of it
and it's awful sometimes you all
are and you just get together and you
just you're dumping all of your boxes
out on the table
that's why um that's what wine was
invented for right
you sit there and you just work it out
then there's other times when
um you're gonna bring your positivity
here's a great example
and of how i think was it was a was a
signal that i've got a beautiful
friendship
with a guy that i've known for gosh 20
or 30 years now
my buddy he's the most stable guy i know
i may have even told this on the show
before he's the most stable guy i know
he called me do over a break
um back in the fall and he said dude my
bank just got bought
i'm gonna be unemployed like i think i'm
gonna lose my job
and that was the same day that i had
gotten a call from my boss to check my
email and the email had told me that i
had just
made the best seller list i made number
two on the best seller list with my
little anxiety book and so my buddy
calls in his worst moment
and he said hey i think i'm gonna get
fired and i responded with
i just made the best seller list and he
responded with
for your little your little pamphlet
book and i was like yeah
and then i said hey you're the most
stable friend i've got you can't be
fired
that rocks my world and so in a quick
exchange
i didn't have to hide the good stuff
that was going on in my life
he felt safe to tell me the crappy awful
stuff that was going on in his life
we made a few jokes and then when it was
over
he said man i'm really proud of you
you've been working for a long time to
be good at that stuff
awesome and i said hey man if i can help
with anything i'd love to have you all
out of the house we can just sit down
and talk about this
and share this in person and they're
actually coming to visit us in a couple
of weeks
so good friends don't have to hide the
good stuff don't have to hide the bad
stuff they don't have to filter
themselves in front of their friends
and so backing out of that if you show
up to a house feeling like you have to
perform
i want to challenge you to turn that off
you show up and be full aaron because
the world deserves full errand
now there's parts of aaron that may be
super annoying and frustrating are there
oh yeah okay see me too i'm a lot
and the beautif the beautiful part about
having friends is they say hey deloney
how about you dial it back about 30
you're a lot right and usually they're
right
and we all laugh or i say you're an
idiot and they say you're an idiot and
then we get something to eat
right and then there's other times when
man aaron's gonna
bless that entire table right she is
going to be the person that can
with her quiet gravity can absorb some
of the pain people are feeling
makes sense out of some of the chaos in
people's lives and it becomes a gift
that only happens when you show up not
for a transaction not for performance
but just to be aaron with your friends
if after a couple of times you're full
errand
and they stop inviting you out or
you can tell that you're off-putting
they don't like you
then man yeah that's not your gang
that's not your crew
right you're going to want to find other
people to
be in community with or they may just
roll their eyes and
you stay at the table and you say a dumb
joke and it lands
awful it's like a thud c'thunk
and then you just say that steve but
they don't even funny joke and they're
like yeah that wasn't funny then you all
move on
and you're not thinking about at the end
of the day because that's your that's
your squad that's your gang
so yes go be with friends who are
driving you crazy
but only if you can be fully you and you
can drive them a little bit crazy
if you show up fully you shoulders down
you bring the foods that you think are
good
you're a hospitable person you welcome
people into your life and they just cut
you out
so be it their loss right and you can
also learn things from them too if
you're being a jerk you're being rude
which you're not
but if you are then you can learn um
some social skills too
so show up be fully you if they don't
like that if that's not their thing then
cool there's gonna be a group of people
that
love aaron for aaron right and at the
end of the day should you continue
friendships
you find draining no you shouldn't but
only when you're fully you
if you're performing in this training
yeah it's exhausting right theater's
exhausting
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for ten percent off
your first month
this is less expensive than traditional
therapy and you're
worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today let's
go to ann
in waverly and what is going on
good morning dr john how are you how are
you today i'm great
how are you i'm doing all right
fantastic
to have this weird uh i don't know it's
like allergies of some sort i feel like
i'm talking an octave lower
but anytime anybody says allergies
everyone goes sure covet right
so whatever i've got something going on
but it's cool and you you're doing well
i'm doing all right yeah fantastic let's
get over a cold it was not covered it
was
sure sure it was ann c19
we all know what you have all right so
hey what's going on how can i help
well so i have a 21 year old son
you sound like you're dealing with you
sound 25
well i'm not well well done well done
you're keeping that
you're keeping your voice young and well
done well hopefully i keep the rest of
me young too then
i can't even comment on that it's the
21st century but i will tell you
good job good work on the voice so far i
sound like a 90 year old man
so you have 21 year old and then what he
is struggling with anxiety and
depression
and i feel like everything we do to try
to help him is wrong
how do we know if we are actually
helping him or are we enabling him
oh if you're helping him he gets more
anxious and more depressed right
so what what is that what does that look
like
you know it's gosh it's been a long few
years here with this
it's been a roller coaster ride that we
just can't seem to get off it never ends
and he has obviously good days he has
bad days
and the bad days are bad
you know there's anger there's holes in
my walls there's broken things around my
house on those angry days
yeah and then it turns into i don't want
to come home
because i don't know who i'm going to
get am i going to get
the you know happy-go-lucky kid that i
remember from
his childhood or am i going to get this
angry swollen
monster nobody wants to be around
so when did this start
probably it started when he was in high
school
it's progressively gotten worse and
we've tried therapy we we did therapy
when he was a minor and he had no choice
to go
because we made him go which isn't
necessarily the greatest thing either
because
you know you don't want to be there
you're not going to do the work
once he was old enough he quit going
when we couldn't make him go anymore
he has recently started seeing somebody
again
but i don't think it's very often i
think it's maybe
you know once once a month once every
few weeks
kind of a thing okay and i feel like he
needs to be there weekly right now
okay so
he's living in our home by the way i
think i think i made that clear
about that is he in school or anything
he is not
he is actually currently doing nothing
and that is
just maddening to my husband and i we
just we
we can't wrap our heads around that some
days he doesn't get out of bed
yeah and then it's and then you're like
okay well that this is a depression
thing and we can't just
make him go away because we know that
you know that
he can't sit in an apartment and do that
and days on end nobody knows
so he can and that's where this is gonna
get hard so i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be honest with you as we walk
through this okay
okay and when you hang up you can say i
don't like that guy and
lucky for you you didn't this is all
free right so
this may be worth the price you pay for
it
um before
i'm gonna be super honest as transparent
as i can be and i need you to promise me
as a mom
that you will be able to hear this
within with a
vision for moving forward not trying to
replay the past is that cool
absolutely we need to move forward these
are hard things to hear okay
the last thing i want to ask was get a
little bit more information
did anything set this off does he come
from
was home chaotic does do either you or
your husband struggle with depression or
anxiety was there were you all ever
medicated growing up
is there divorce was he abused what
anything that set any of this off
nope his dad and i have been married for
25 years
been together forever and there's you
know we've
in my opinion had a good home life you
know they had
you know they the kids have had a good
upbringing and it's not been
you know there wasn't chaos there wasn't
fighting we don't
you know my husband and i don't have
knock down drag out brawl type things
you know
obviously we argue because we're a
married couple and that happens wait
what just kidding yeah
right nobody nobody argues in marriage
never never
especially in my house so do you there's
never yelling there's never
anything like that did he experience
bullying or abuse at school
did he have a bad breakup did somebody
treat him awful
yes he had a bad breakup okay um but it
was years ago
okay um he's had bad breakups since then
okay you know he's had a long-term
girlfriend that's been off and on
and that hasn't helped matters sure um
she you know they they just they they
they butt heads and it's just not been
good for either of them
okay but that's up to them they gotta
fix that and i know that and i don't get
involved in that i just
stay away and say that's not my business
and you guys need to work it out
okay um so here's um here's
here's what next steps look like he's
21.
he's a grown man who has absolutely no
business punching holes in the walls of
your house
he doesn't get to do that he doesn't
give to live rent free
under a blanket in his room and do
nothing
he's got to experience the reality of
the world
um to say it like my friend henry cloud
says it
he's got to get some problems and he
doesn't have any
and here's where that gets really hard
if he's had years of depression he's
probably threatened suicide or talked
about
vaguely i want to hurt myself or i'm
having dark thoughts or things like that
and those often i don't mess around with
that i call in
the calvary when people that i love
threaten suicide
and i've worked with thousands of
college kids and high school kids over
the years
and when they want to be seen and heard
they can say the phrase i'm having dark
thoughts and the entire institution
shuts down
from the president down that's how they
they they ha they earn control that way
and i take it real real serious you will
never hear me say the words
they're just faking it never right
um but they can control everything
and so at some point he needs to know he
can no longer control you
he can no longer run your home and he's
running your home
he's running your marriage he's running
everything
and you can't give him that anymore he's
a 21 year old man
and if he walks out the door and hurts
himself
this is going to be hard to hear that
would be a choice he made
especially if you tell him i'm this your
rent here runs out your top lease here
runs out
and we love you and we will always be
here we're going to have sunday dinner
on the table every sunday and we want
you here if you
ever want to go get coffee we're here to
talk
but at this point he's a 21 year old man
so if you put things like if you want
to still be on our car insurance or
still want us to pay for your phone
but you have to fill in the blank then
you're using power and threats and it
doesn't work
it just doesn't you become a politician
at that point
right now you transition up to we love
you and support you
and here's our boundaries you don't
punch holes in our walls
you don't you don't lay in your bed all
day at our house
if you're having a depressive episode we
understand that those are real
we expect you to go do the work to go
meet with a professional who's going to
walk you through that
you get a job so you can afford the
health insurance so you can get
a low dose medication while you work
whatever you need to do right
um but he's 21 and he's got to start
making some hard decisions on his own
and that starts with him realizing
there's not going to be people wiping
his butt anymore
and there's not gonna be people making
his bed anymore and not people at his
beck and call who are scared to death to
move the wrong way because he controls
y'all
oh man egg shells yeah we got a lot of
them around our house
and here's what happens with eggshells
in your home do you have younger kids in
the home
i have another son yes how old is he
he's
16. okay
and he's absorbing every second of this
i know
that's part of our that's really part of
our problem is we
we know he's seeing this we've talked to
him about it you know and
we've told him you know this is this is
going to end
we've my husband and i have talked about
you know
making a plan to get him out and my
older son not my younger sister
he has to live here until he's done with
high school um
about getting him out and you know
frankly
i mean we've talked to the point where
we said let's let's
you know put up the money to put a
deposit down in the rent the first month
rent on an apartment and tell him the
rest is on him
he's moved out before he hasn't lived
here every day since high school sure he
has moved out before and he did live on
his own
and that's where one of the nasty
breakups came and he came back
well he never left and it's been a while
and
it's time for him to go we know this we
know this
it's just oh my gosh so here's a here's
a
cool here's a cool way to do this
go out with your husband and y'all get
off campus off-site i call houses camp
like get get out of the house and y'all
go spend a half day together
and i want y'all to mourn the kid that
you love with all your heart
because you're still trying to hold on
to that 12 year old little boy
all right let me tell you this yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you a story that's
not fair
okay i was i've been out of town for a
few
for several days i got back home and
while i was gone i missed my son's fifth
grade to sixth grade
like the fifth grade there's a
graduation for everything now when i was
a kid we had one
and now there's a million of them right
there's a fifth grade ceremony of some
sort
and he won a couple of nerd awards
because his parents are dorks and he won
some academic awards because he and he
works really hard
and i pulled up my my truck and he ran
outside he just got done with sh
with his shower he ran outside with his
big
poofy hairdo in his underwear met me in
my truck so i've been gone for several
days holding these certificates
and i pulled him up he's about eight
feet tall now even though he's 11
and i pulled him up into the truck i
didn't even have time to get out
and he told me the story of the awards
and the certificates and
the nice thing that a teacher said was
one of the
awesomest moments of my parenting life
and you've had those and now you looked
up and it's 10 years after that
and you remember those and that same
little boy is now a grown man punching
holes in your wall
and what you've got to do is you've got
to put down that 11 year old little boy
that you're still trying to hang on to
and deal with the 21 year old man that's
terrorizing your home
yep and i know that's hard so i want you
and your husband to go out i want you to
mourn that
talk about it laugh about it and spend
some time saying
remember when remember when and then
move that toggle to
and here's where now is and be really
clear
on the same page is it going to be 30
days is it going to be 45 days
are we gonna give him five hundred
dollars are we gonna give him no dollars
um i if i like sounding all tough and
hard like yeah you tell him
i would do what you're doing i would put
down a deposit
and say we found you an apartment we put
down a deposit for you we're not giving
you
cash we're going to give them a deposit
so that we l
we love you and i'll even go do a mom
thing and i'll put some cereal in your
in your i don't you know what i mean
i'll fill your bridge because i'm your
mom and you got to eat
maybe maybe i'll give you a dozen eggs
yes and then hey this is it
you're a grown man and then on sundays
you come to our house and we're gonna
have lunch
and we will always answer the phone when
you call but you're not moving back in
and we'll we will call our friend so and
so if you say you need a job we'll help
but here's our boundaries i want you and
your husband to work out those
boundaries together
and then look each other in the eye and
commit this is it
because you got a 16 year old in that
house that deserves your full attention
and you know what else deserves your
full attention you need your marriage
back
yes we do you lose your intimacy nobody
wants to
nobody wants to have sex when there's a
hole in the wall right nobody wants to
go on dates when you're worried about
what a 21 year old
person in your house who's struggling is
going to do to the house right
everything gets messed up and you all
deserve your marriage back
right yes so
yeah we're all the one thing that we
have stayed
pretty confident about this is that we
are we still connect with each other
good job man good job different it's
different when there's a 21 year old in
here that you're
that you're you're scared that there's
going to be chaos that's right you're
scared of right
so here's the thing i'm proud of you i
know this is hard
but it ends today it ends today
um you got i would give you 30 days from
today
and the moment y'all make this you're
going to be nervous and you're going to
be and
you're also going to start feeling
relief your 16 year old son's gonna feel
relief i want y'all to take him out
talk about what y'all did right about
this talk about hey we let this go on
too long and we're sorry
you're our son and double down on that
one and if your
older son calls and threatens to hurt
himself call 9-1-1
call 9-1-1 send in the cavalry send in
the professionals to deal with a grown
man making threats
okay and be there for him but you got to
let him go
thank you so much for the call and hey
and how about this i'm going to send you
a copy
i'll send you two we're going to stay on
the line we're going to send you two
copies of
my book redefining anxiety let me send
it to you for free
give one to him it's easy to read and he
may throw it at you or whatever
that's fine it's not gonna hurt my
feelings and i want you as a family to
read the other one that way you have a
picture
of some ways you can navigate this you
cannot fix your son
you can just love him and you can love
him by starting by holding boundaries
right
so hang on the line here kelly we'll
send you a couple of copies of that book
for you and your family
let's take one more call let's go to
emily
in pensacola florida emily what is going
on
oh hey there how are you i'm good how
are you
yeah thank you so much for having me i
love your show thank you i love that you
love my show that's so great
what's going on how can i help um
so i'm a military wife and we're moving
quite a bit this year about like every
four to six months
and it's starting to just become a
little stressful
so i was just wondering if you had any
advice on coping with being a new
place and moving jobs and all of that
you said that so i don't think you just
told me the truth emily
so you have to rephrase it in truthful
the way you would say it if you were
hanging out with a few of friends that
you've known for 25 years
if you've moved a few times this year
it's more than quote unquote a little
bit stressful
describe what it's like moving again
it's hard more
it sucks tell the truth there's no lying
on the show keep going
i don't know i miss a lot of things you
know i miss my job and i miss my friends
and my family and
so
and more how do you feel about it
you're giving me some great military
answers
hello honey what is the mission for
today the mission is eggs and bacon like
how do you feel about it um
i feel pretty sad what does that look
like
um well when you're in a new place
you know i used to be a teacher but i
can't really teach when we're only
in somewhere four to six months at a
time because you need to be somewhere
nine months
um so it looks a lot like me being alone
during the day
kind of trying to find things to do
you're telling me as though
you are on real world or real housewives
or something and somebody's watching it
i don't want to watch it i want you to
tell me how does it feel when you're
sitting in your house
by yourself in the third new city
in one calendar year
it feels pretty helpless sometimes
what does hopeless feel like um
pretty dark yeah like i i just don't
know what to do
lonely yes
very lonely exhausted
yes and then you spend
all the time you can on your phone
trying to connect with somebody in some
way and somehow
and you get these great ideas all right
i'm gonna go to
the library or the coffee shop and i'm
gonna and you get there and it's almost
more lonely because you're lonely in a
crowded room so you just go back home
and you watch something or text somebody
am i on the right track
um a hundred percent yeah
who have you told this
um i've talked to my husband about it a
little bit
and um i recently kind of called my
parents and told them
yeah how long have you been married
um we got married last july so get into
a year
okay and how long is this cycle going to
last is this a season
or is this for the rest of your marriage
it's a
it's a season um it's like
i mean we'll always move but usually
we'll be somewhere two or three years at
a time which i'm
i'm like hanging on until we get
stationed my husband
he's in training right now okay so we
have live
and six more months six more months okay
um
we have one more like six more month
move so i have four more months here one
more six more months
and then hope the plan is they put us
somewhere for two or three years
so you you haven't you have another year
of
having to be really flexible yes okay
is your um does your husband get to come
home or is he off for four weeks at a
time
is he coming home every day nine to five
yeah okay uh
not nine to five his schedule's
different every day and it's pretty
very very long days and then you know he
has to study for the next day too
so he he has a lot on his plate right
now yeah but he's still home
that's nice well so here's what i'm
asking is is there
time that you can go spend a few weeks
in chunks
with former friends with people that you
care about
with your family yeah
i could for sure do that and i'm
thinking back
um i spent some time with some military
folks this week
um and we just talked about just offline
um not on stage just talked about
the the military spouses
are as involved as critical to the
military
functioning as the actual soldiers are
right as the actual
enlisted people are because what you'll
have to do is so so hard
and they call it a sacrifice for a
reason it's really really hard
and in this season that you're in right
now
every two to three years for me sounds
like a lot
but every four to six weeks or every
four six months sounds just like chaos
right and yeah it feels a little chaotic
right now
there are seasons when the only i have
no comparison to what you're going
through so i don't want to minimize what
y'all are experiencing but
i remember when i was writing my
dissertations or when i was working on a
book or working on a big project there
was times when i was
home yet completely unavailable i would
work all day
write all night and it became so
draining um it became best for my wife
and even we had little kids
they would go spend a week with her
parents a week with my parents and go
visit friends
it allowed them to go have some fun
adventures to get some community
and it allowed me to totally plug in
because then i felt guilty too
and then all of us were just doing this
weird guilt
toilet bowl dance where we just i felt
like we were flushing
down the commode right is there some
ways you can get out and go see some
folks because here's the thing
if you were moving here for two to three
years
i would be really insistent you gotta go
first go
meet wives go get into the local
community go
be hyper intentional about making
friends and you're a teacher you are
great at helping new faces feel
safe and feel connected that's your
spiritual gift right that's
that's like what the cosmos gave you um
but man you're there for six months
you're gonna get just enough
relationship
to feel sad when you have to move again
right
yeah and and i did try to get really
involved quickly when we moved here but
i i know it takes about six months to
kind of start to get settled and
make like real friendships and stuff so
just in just for you just the time to
leave
with it yeah yeah you'll always have
this thing hanging over you
and so there's something about you got
to be around other people
and so going to have fun with other
people right if there's thing are y'all
living on base are you living off
we're off base right now okay um if
there's ways you can if there's things
you can do with the local church just to
go have some but we
go have some fun if there's ways you can
get involved in a local ymca
you know all these things right because
you've looked them up and tried to
pretend you were going to do them even
though you're not
um yeah there's similar things that
you've you can do
and look at those as opportunities to
have fun not an opportunity to make best
friends
right does that make sense yes there's a
difference there
and i want you and your husband to have
some real conversations about you going
and spending some time with your parents
go spend some time with some folks let
him study let him be all in
on this training and then when y'all go
move again
you can start getting settled right
is that making sense yes that makes a
lot of sense
here's the other more sense than what
i've tried to do well here's the other
thing it's okay to be sad right now
and i know that sounds bonkers but
you're in the middle of a hard season
right and so you may have heard me say
this often but
just because winter shows up it doesn't
mean that summer's broken
it's just it means that it's winter this
is the season right now and it's not fun
it's cold it's miserable it's gray
sun doesn't come out um
and you just are in that season and
that's where you are right now
and so it's incumbent on you to own the
sadness it just sucks
i hate it i hate sitting in my house
alone and so
i'm then going to make sure i've got a
facetime
group not just a text group because it's
going to make you nuts i will
never ever check the news
because those things are built to spin
you out right i'm going to go exercise
every single day
i'm going to go be around other people
not to make best friends forever but
just to have some fun
just we're going to go bowling we're
going to go to silly stuff we're just
going to get together with some of the
wives and we're just going to
complain and be loud and go fill
whatever whatever
right and what you're doing is there is
a little bit of passing the time there
is a little bit about you
growing this may be a great time for you
to get an online master's degree in a
thing
right whatever that is how can you grow
yourself
so that in a year when you all land and
put some
roots in man then you're ready to rock
and roll does that make sense
yes that makes a lot of sense so some of
it's in a hundred percent of it's
intentional some of us just owning the
season
and i hate that for you and i hope that
everybody listening to this
man we talk a lot about um a lot about
this the sacrifices our service men and
women make and god almighty they do
let's not forget their spouses their
wives their husbands the folks who are
holding this thing together with string
and duct tape
while they're off training they're off
on deployment
they're off learning new things running
night and day and day and night
there's somebody sitting at home trying
to wrangle kids there is somebody
sitting at home
completely alone in a new town and then
a new town and then a new town
so if you know of community of people in
your community who are
transitioning or transitory or moving in
but be
really hospitable invite them over have
a dance party in your front yard have a
barbecue out in your driveway
be hospitable to folks who are new to
the neighborhood
who are just going to be there six
months everybody will be lifted up with
those interactions
emily thank you for your service
it's a winter season right now
relationally it's gonna warm up again i
promise
do the things intentionally they're
gonna keep you healthy make sure you're
plugging in make sure you're visiting
people that you love and care about
make sure you're being honest and open
about your feelings with your husband
and then y'all hang on there hang on the
season is going to come to an end
and there's going to be a place where
you can plant deep trees that we're
going to grow deep or not deep trees
you're going to plant trees
that will grow deep roots all right as
we wrap up today's show
let's do this one man in honor of my new
walmart cd
off the 1986 record the masterpiece
about addiction oh man i gave it away
what a dork
man it's like when you watch a trailer
of a movie and they're like you'll never
guess the twist ending and you're like
well now's not twist ending genius
but 1986 record the self-titled
master of puppets the song is master of
puppets and it goes like this
end of passion play these lyrics are so
dramatic they're so great
end of passion play crumbling away i'm
your source of self-destruction
veins that pump with fear sucking
darkest clear
leaning on your death's construction
death's construction that's what's up
taste me you will see more is all you
need you're dedicated to how i'm killing
you
come crawling faster obey your
master master master of puppets i'm
pulling your strings
i guess that's master of puppets if a
muppet was singing it right
this has been the dr john dolone's show
[Music]